thanks very much for coming you're
welcome nice to have you with us
especially since i understand you're
going through a bit of a hard time right
now a little bit of controversy
about your children's book mr chaz and
lisa sue
meet the pandas what's going on um well
i've heard from
a great number of panda experts um
you're probably surprised as i was to
discover there are a great number of
panda experts
and uh they have taken issue i actually
um
chose pandas at random just as a fun
animal to frolic with the children
they occurred to me for no reason i know
so little about the natural world
that i had no idea that they were even
from china you didn't know pandas were
from china no
even i know that all right i didn't know
they're from china i didn't know they
were rare i mean
you could easily have convinced me that
the lawns of greenwich were filled with
cavorting pandas it could have been
squirrels i thought of pandas
and um i started getting letters uh when
the
hardcover came out wait what are these
panda experts mad about what
what have you done to these panties i
feel that i have misrepresented
the panda
i mean i've actually got letters to say
pandas don't eat pizza
really pandas eat bamboo which in fact
is why they're rare
because there are apparently fewer and
fewer bamboo trees
okay and that's why there are no pandas
that is right so clearly they should eat
pizza
[Laughter]
we should send them pizzas yeah
definitely um
these pandas talk so i was obviously
which is another pull the wool over the
eyes of the american public
and you know um i once um wrote a piece
for newsweek
about teenagers and where i made a
disparaging remark about guidance
counselors
and i heard from about 80 million
guidance counselors
and i think there's really an equation
to be made here i mean considering the
fact that we need none
the fact that there are 80 million
guidance counselors and
an equal number of panda experts who i
feel actually have been the students of
these guidance counselors
causing a lot of trouble okay
yeah so what are you gonna do i mean
have you learned a lesson next time will
you research the animal that uh
no you don't care no i actually um
offending panda experts really just
rolls right off my back
i'm not running for anything i don't
have to appease the panda expert faction
i see i don't know how you sleep at
night i don't
yeah okay now i understand in a similar
vein you've been working on the same
novel now for quite a long time it's
probably since you were born
really i feel like 1978 um well actually
not much after that i feel that it is
important in this changing world to have
something stay the same
and so i've clearly chosen this book to
be the thing in my life that's the
constant that's the constant
literally how can you work on a novel
it's it's how close to completion are
you on this thing now
that's really hard to tell it depends on
how much distraction there is
i mean i could spend months on the panda
experts so um
i would say that um i'm getting uh i'm
getting toward the middle
okay and you've been getting so so this
is literally years and years you've been
working on the same
no i haven't been working on it for
years and years it's just been due for
years and years
you know being a writer is just very
much like being a high school student
without of course the fun
um i mean it's like always having a term
paper do the only problem is you can't
do it the night before it's due
i know that since i've tried it twice
so i just said i have poor working
habits uh-huh
i understand well well you've done both
now you've you've been writing
real adult books not real adult books i
shouldn't say that you've been writing
adult books
and you've been writing children's book
what what is easier to do
um children's books really yes why is
that um
well they're easier to fool
which is why we like them it's just
easier because
i'm childish i guess it's easier they're
fewer words okay
um the whole thing is much less
complicated and there are pictures that
take up a lot of the space
so what happens when what happens when
you go on tv shows say like this one and
you say
writing children's books is is easy
easier
easier do do children's book authors now
get mad you're going to get letters from
them
yes you will yes you've offended them
now
yes but they writing crayon on shirt
cardboard
all right it's not that threatening it's
not a threatening thing
now we talked about this the last time
you were on but uh you don't like
and you admit to this you cop to this
you don't you don't like having people
around do you
you really don't not in my own home no
you don't like having people in your
home that's correct
okay what's correct that's what home
means home means
the absence of anyone but me that's
right that's why
i call it fran land
and fran land there's just not room for
others
so that this apartment that i have now i
uh tore out two bedrooms
um why because uh they would be thought
of by others as guest rooms
[Laughter]
that's pretty extreme to actually rip
out guest rooms
on the odd chance that someone might
misconstrue it as a place to hang out
it's not an odd chance if you live in
new york and you have a guest room you
have a guest
yeah that's true that's true it's not
like you live you know some place out of
the way
i mean it's not like you could freely
say to people if you ever happen to be
in new york you can stay with me it's
it's gonna happen every airline goes
through new york through my
apartment actually now what about is
this does this extend to family
as well or particularly the family uh no
as my mother stayed with me once
my parents live in new jersey so there's
not really necessary for them to stay
overnight but
on this occasion my mother wanted to
stay in europe for the weekend so i
allowed it since i thought you know
she's my mother i have only 101 start a
trend
you know people want to say i'm also
your mother i can stay here so
okay so my mother is allowed to stay
there and that went well you you could
share the same space and it was okay
well i slept on the sofa no you know so
it was okay
there you go for my mother
now what about in just in life walking
down the street you interact well with
people outside your apartment then are
you perfectly happy to see people
no i'm not perfectly happy to see them
but unfortunately i'm not in control of
them
so okay although they feel they're in
control of you you know they make all
these rules but
um i ignore them okay this is a nice
attitude you've got going
very warm and fuzzy yes well it works
for me my mood hair is changing as we
speak
i feel very threatened by this whole
thing now
hi there the um
how do you feel you're also a bit of uh
you have a fear i don't know what the
technical term is fear of technology or
you don't trust technology you don't
like technology
i would say a distaste for technology
okay a contempt
contempt yes all right that's that's the
other side of fear
how does this manifest itself i mean i
don't know how to work anything
if it if if so like a chair you can
handle this you're doing fine
if it was invented after my childhood
which was last time i learned anything
um i can't work it and um so i just
don't have any modern things
well what about you're a writer do you
work on a word processor or a computer
i write with a pen okay but like a nice
pen
like a fancy pen um no i i write with a
pen numb that is called a bic
click which is an old-fashioned um
it's an old-fashioned um ballpoint pen
they're very hard to find now
i mentioned the brand name in case
anyone would like to send me some okay
um
you know you press down the thing you
know you i'm familiar with that concept
and you can handle that i press down on
this button and the
point emerges right as opposed to more
modern pens which you sometimes have to
turn and they're too complicated
so if you sat down to write and there
was a turning pen there would you freak
out and run out of your empty apartment
an excellent excuse to not write for a
few weeks
all right uh boy where are you going to
end up i guess is the good question i
mean
is it where is this leading where do you
see yourself
going say if if if technology just keeps
encroaching on us i mean it's getting
harder and harder to avoid
more and more people are using on you
know our online with computers and it's
becoming such a part of life
aren't you going to just have to flee
the country at some point live in
greenland or something with your big
clique or whatever it's called and they
probably have it there too
okay a panda will sell it to you on the
street yeah i mean the more things they
invent and the less i know gives me less
in common with other people and they're
less likely to want to
be guests
it's a beautiful theory i love it
all right well my thanks to uh bran
leibowitz for for
sharing your philosophy with us very
refreshing the book is mr chaz and lisa
sue meet the pandas it's now in
paperback go out but don't buy the stuff
about the pandas right
we should warn the children at home they
don't eat pizza buy it but don't believe
it
okay fran leewards thank you very much
you